Okay guys, so this is how you trade a continuation of the trend. So obviously this is a high onset, right? But I just want to explain it to you how you can trade the continuation of the trend. Orderful. In the continuation of the trend, right? So let me show you what's going on here. So we created a lower low, lower high. And then we created another lower lower, right? This could be the lower low, right around here.
So what you can see here is that let me remove that. We broke the structure here and this there is imbalance around here, right? There's no imbalance here.
Here or here. Okay, it's all filled.
So this should be our entry zone, okay, but then we got autoblog here.
So this would have been your first entry.
Okay, and you would target this zone right around here.
Now once price creates another low,
which it does right here, you can see that there's imbalance around here and this is the
auto block, okay? There's no imbalance around here. Every imbalance is filled within this trend.
So what do we do? We take our position from here, put our shop plus right above there and we target the
low here and as you can see price hit or take profit level. Now let me give you an
example for the buy positions.